[Musique]
florence granger eu bonjour et bienvenue
je vous en prie installez vous pour
votre café politique
oap trio à montigny le bretonneux vous
avez été élu voici six mois maintenant
face à david douillet sur la
circonscription plaisir poissy on vous
connaît encore assez peu finalement en
politique puisque vous étiez novice
avant ce scrutin vous avez à 55 ans vous
êtes juriste de formation pendant la
campagne vous disiez ce n'est pas parce
que je n'ai pas d'expérience en
politique que je n'ai pas d'idée parce
que ces idées aujourd'hui vous arrivez à
les faire entendre dans l'hémicycle où
est-ce que c'est compliqué
l'objectif c'est de faire entendre les
idées partout c'est à dire que j'ai
choisi d'être une députée de proximité
une députée de terrain j'ai choisi
d'écouter les citoyennes et les citoyens
pendant la campagne législative
j'ai pris un certain nombre
d'engagements et aujourd'hui l'objectif
bien évidemment c'est de faire remonter
les préoccupations à des habitants donc
de ma circonscription de les faire
remonter que ce soit en groupe de
travail que ce soit également en
commission la commission des affaires
sociales que mission à laquelle
j'appartiens que ce soit auprès d'autres
commissions via des députés qui sont sur
telle ou telle thématique et puis
également bien évidemment dans
l'hémicycle et est ce que la politique
est difficile vous qu'il découvrait ce
milieu alors je découvre l'autre côté le
je découvre une la partie cachée de
l'iceberg parce que je
j'ai une expérience de trente années
dans le service public le service public
de l'emploi
quand vous travaillez dans le service
public bien évidemment vous rencontrés
quotidiennement les acteurs économiques
les acteurs locaux et donc les élus vous
rencontrer les élus quasiment je dirais
quotidiennement sur les dossiers ce qui
veut dire que j'ai l'habitude de
travailler avec des élus en revanche
aujourd'hui je suis devenue une femme
politique puisque j'ai été élu sous
l'étiquette la république en marche donc
je porte également un programme
présidentiel
ce qui veut dire qu'à un moment donné
effectivement on va me poser des
questions que je me posais pas
habituellement quand j'étais la femme de
service public donc là c'est ça peut
être différent maintenant à partir du
moment où on oeuvre toujours dans
l'intérêt général et le député il est là
toujours pour oeuvrer dans l'intérêt
général pour expliquer également ce
qu'il fait comment le fait pourquoi on
le fait je crois que les choses sont
bien entendu vous évoquez votre parcours
justement 30 ans dans le domaine de
l'emploi notamment comme la directrice
des agences locales pour l'emploi les
mesures qui se met aujourd'hui en place
dans cette thématique là sur ce secteur
là vous satisfont je les ai fortement
portée mais pendant la campagne des
législatives alors pourquoi j'ai été
fortement portée et bien parce que je
crois que le droit du travail que nous
avions n'étaient pas adaptés ils
n'étaient pas adaptés il était je dirais
fait essentiellement pour les grandes
entreprises pour les grandes structures
alors quand je sais pas si vous voyez
mais dans l'hémicycle je suis juste
positionné derrière les insoumis et un
jour ils sont arrivés avec le code du
travail
donc on voyait un code de travail épais
comme ça oui vous allez casser le code
du travail d'écouté quand j'ai débuté il
ya trente ans je suis juriste de
formation
le code du travail s'était mis l'article
il était épais comme ça aujourd'hui vous
m'apportez un code du travail dans
l'hémicycle il est trois fois plus épais
est ce que vous pensez qu'on a moins
licencier est ce que vous pensez que
lorsqu'on veut licencier quelqu'un une
entreprise elle trouve pas le bon
juriste qui saura faire dire à la loi ce
qu'elle veut donc bien sûr que je suis
tout à fait satisfaite et d'ailleurs on
a porté ses ordonnances
travail on a fait des ateliers citoyens
on a eu beaucoup de questions pour du
dialogue social j'ai rencontré également
les représentants du syndicat sur le
territoire j'ai une rencontre échange de
deux heures et je pense que ce qui est
important c'est d'expliquer ce qu'on
fait d'expliquer le diagnostic qu'on a
fait on vous sont déterminés engagés on
va reparler de vos actions mais c'est
une parenthèse qu'est ce qui vous a
motivé pour vous lancer en politique et
rejoindre le mouvement republic en
marche parce qu'auparavant vous n'étiez
encarté dans aucun parti aucun jamais de
cartes politiques toujours fortement
intéressé par ce qui se passait d'accord
mais jamais de cartes politiques
alors il ya plusieurs choses un pour moi
la montée d'extrême droite qui m'est
insupportable
ensuite l'utilisation des deniers
publics quand vous êtes une femme de
service public et que vous devez rendre
compte sur le moindre euro dépensé il ya
des choses que vous pouvez pas accepter
d'accord et puis ensuite la démarche
également qui a été celle d' emmanuel
macron à savoir de faire des ateliers
citoyens de construire un programme à
partir des remontées des préoccupations
des questionnements et puis également le
fait qu'on l'entendait eh bien il ya de
bonnes idées à droite il ya de bonnes
idées à gauche il ya de bonnes idées au
centre et l'objectif c'est de faire
avancer toutes et tous ensemble la
france et là je me suis dit ça
correspond tout à fait à ce que j'ai
envie de faire et comment j'ai envie de
travailler parce que je pense que les
bonnes idées
elles sont partout et dont se lancer à
55 ans ce n'est pas évident c'est tout
comme thomas dit mais attention il ya
david douillet enfin je dis oui mais il
ya un programme bien chose et puis il ya
des marcheurs donc j'ai été fortement
également et d appuyer accompagnés par
les marcheurs pendant la campagne
et puis j'ai adoré cette partie cette
période de campagne
et puis là près aussi même si
effectivement c'est beaucoup de travail
et votre famille aussi vous a soutenu
ou est-ce que c'était difficile de faire
accepter justement 55 euros de dia bombe
à quoi je vais m'engager en politique
ma famille a été très inquiète parce que
ma famille c'est une chose c'est que je
suis la femme très engagée et je ne
supporte pas qu'il n'y ait pas lorsqu'il
ya un problème qu'on ne trouve pas de
solution j'ai été pendant sept ans
directeur territorial délégué pôle
emploi en seine-saint-denis
la seine-saint-denis personne ne voulait
prendre ce poste je m'occupais de la
partie la plus difficile la zone de
sécurité numéro un en seine saint denis
c'est à dire les agences de saint-denis
d'aubervilliers de c'est un des pilotes
des agences dans les cas il y avait tous
les jours des problématiques j'avais des
semaines très très importante en termes
d'horaires donc ma famille s'est dit à
un moment donné mais est-ce que tu
réalises que tu vas avoir 23 communes
est-ce que tu réalises que tu vas être
sollicités et que plus tu vas faire et
mieux tu vas faire bien évidemment et
plus tu sera sollicitée tu vas y passer
jours et nuits
je confirme je confirme jean-yves et oui
jour et nuit en ce moment six jours et
nuits sur 7
voilà six jours et demi sur sa traque le
dimanche après midi où j'essaye de me
dire bon il faut que je fasse autre
chose mais quand vous êtes sollicité par
quelqu'un qui a une problématique ce
soit une problématique au niveau de la
commune par un maire qui vous dit ben là
il ya un problème ou par un habitant qui
vous dis là j'arrive pas à passer vous
êtes avant tout quelqu'un citoyenne
engagée vous avez toujours essayer
d'apporter des solutions donc bien
évidemment vous y passez beaucoup de
temps
je reviens vos engagements ce que vous
prenez tout au long de cette campagne on
a en particulier c'est l'égalité filles
garçons ont parlé un petit peu
alors oui effectivement
l'égalité filles garçons c'est dans les
écoles exactement on va mettre en place
on a déjà commencé on a mis en place un
concours en fait l'objectif
c'est de faire prendre conscience déjà
très jeune que l'égalité est bien c'est
important c'est primordial et ses deux
plus jeunes enfants plus jeune âge par
donc il faut faire prendre conscience
aux enfants qu'il faut pas qu'il y ait
de différence pas de différence sur les
tâches ménagères pas différent sur le
savoir être pas de différence au niveau
des rémunérations
donc on a lancé un concours dans toutes
les écoles de la circonscription avec
une production qui sera fait par les
enfants dont sur une grande feuille et
l'objectif c'est que via des verbatim
via des dessins ya des mots il exprime
en quoi les filles sont ne sont pas les
égales des garçons voilà alors ce qui
est étonnant c'est que lorsqu'on a lancé
ce concours on à visualiser des films 10
à 30 ans donc fait et on voit quand on
questionne les enfants qu'on a trente
ans après quasiment les mêmes
problématiques
donc quand marlène schiappa nous dit il
faut et c'est un combat au quotidien
c'est un combat de longue haleine et il
faut pas lâcher on lâchera pas et
lorsque vous voyez alors plus largement
que la parole se libère autour de sa
hotte originalité aussi autour de
harcèlement est-ce que la forme que ça
prend aujourd'hui ça vous ça vous
satisfait quand on voit sur les réseaux
sociaux aussi il ya eu ces hashtag
balance et on peut avoir par exemple des
choses comme ça ce que est ce que tout
ça ça contribue vraiment à libérer la
parole est ce que derrière il y aura
aussi des des actions concrètes qui vont
se mettre en place
alors ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
ça appartient à toutes les personnes qui
s'expriment celles qui font le choix de
s'exprimer ou celles qui font le choix
de ne pas s'exprimer donc là je n'ai pas
je dirais je ne souhaite pas par rapport
à cela
effectivement la parole se libère
pourquoi il se libère il ya
effectivement des moyens de
communication aujourd'hui qui n'existait
pas il ya quelques années en laye les
réseaux sociaux après attention non
attention à ce qui est dit parce que il
doit y avoir dans ces cas-là si la
personne à un moment donné soit je
dirais diffuser l'information et bien
s'il ya un dépôt de plainte s'il ya une
diffamation mais ça c'est la faire celle
affaires de la justice donc
effectivement qu'on voit aujourd'hui le
déchaînement sur les réseaux sociaux oui
ça peut faire peur on peut se poser un
certain nombre de questions mais après
ça peut aussi libérer la parole en
libérant la parole derrière il y aura
des actions concrètes est ce que
l'objectif va avoir des logements place
bien évidemment c'est l'objectif c'est
l'objectif mais il faut toujours rester
très calme il faut les toujours resté
très serein
il faut toujours rester très factuelle
contextualiser prendre ce qui est à
prendre et avancer et je pense que bien
évidemment on est en tout et tous en
train de travailler et d'échanger et on
se rend bien compte c'était l'engagement
ou des manuels
macron de travailler pour l'égalité
hommes-femmes bien pourquoi bien parce
que lorsqu'on a fait campagne
une des premières priorités et
préoccupations des français étaient mais
il ya une problématique d'égalité
hommes-femmes sa remontée vraiment parmi
les sujets prioritaires
donc on s'est dit à un moment donné
comme nos programmes a été comment dire
construit à partir des 500000 remontée
citoyenne on ne pouvait pas ne pas agir
est ce que vous pensez déjà alors je
change complètement de sujets pour parce
qu'on avance dans cette émission mais
est ce que vous pensez déjà aux au
mandat suivant ou pas parce que c'est
votre premier mandat vous n'en avez pas
eu avant est ce que vous déjà vous vous
dites ok je me suis fixé des objectifs
mais j'aimerais bien déjà prolongé sur
le mandat d'après alors je me sers voyez
vous on vous envisagez cet engagement
politique voilà est-ce que c'est juste
ponctuelle ou est-ce que c'est plus dans
la durée alors j'ai toujours été une
citoyenne engagée donc mandat politique
ou pas aujourd'hui j'ai un mandat je
dois dire que je peux pas vous dire
est-ce que j'ai des ambitions politiques
pour après un autre mandat je n'en suis
absolument pas là et j'ai toujours
fonctionné comme ça quand je suis dans
quelque chose pour moi l'important c'est
de bien faire de me consacrer au maximum
et de donner satisfaction
systématiquement des actions que je
conduis que je conduis avec les équipes
et notamment avec mon équipe
parlementaire
après je fais un bilan quand on rentre à
55 en politique je crois qu'on a qu'un
seul objectif qu'une seule ambition
c'est les français ont exprimé un
certain nombre de choses ils ont exprimé
un ras-le-bol
les français très peu à l'érosion
aujourd'hui l'objectif c'est qu'ils
retournent aux urnes
c'est qu'ils aillent voter c'est qui est
véritablement une réponse à leurs
questionnements et qu'on apporte des
solutions et je pense que pour moi
aujourd'hui c'est ma priorité donnée on
verra on va arriver à la fin de cette
émission le petit questionnaire habituel
votre livre de chevet sinon pas
seulement dans le temps de lire oui
alors je vais vous faire sourire c'est
le règlement de l'assemblée nationale et
qu elle a enfin c'est quand je suis
arrivé donc j'ai pu constater une chose
dans l'hémicycle je voyais qu'il y avait
des
des personnes qu'il avait eu deux trois
mandats qui était toujours en train de
regarder un petit bouquin
bleu-blanc-rouge mystique et c'est quoi
ce truc
et quand j'ai compris que c'était le
règlement de l'assemblée nationale je
suis allée la bibliothèque j'ai pris le
règlement de l'assemblée nationale parce
que je crois que mieux on maîtrise le
règlement de l'assemblée nationale
et plus il est facile d'intervenir après
partout dans l'hémicycle en respectant
les règles et ça se pense que c'est
particulièrement important
le dernier film que vous ayez vu ça fait
très longtemps que je suis pas allé au
cinéma
je suis pas le cinéma de qui presque
ouais tu dois te faire un nom à peu près
1 j'ai pas j'ai pas eu le temps
j'ai vu en revanche un très beau fils je
crois que ça doit être le dernier c'est
l' yonne
voilà l'histoire d'un gamin qui peut
grâce à internet en fait retrouvé sa
famille et comme je suis une passionnée
d'internet une passionnée du numérique
est d'ailleurs françois de rugy mme
positionner dans le groupe de travail
sur la transformation numérique
je dois dire qu'on a fait beaucoup
d'ateliers citoyens sur le numérique on
avait des tas d'idées et ça doit
permettre de nous faire avancer et de
faire mieux participer les citoyennes et
des citoyens et une dernière question
est ce qu'il ya une chanson qui pourrait
vous résumer sk une chanson qui nous
inspire le plus écouté si en ce moment
se réfère à l'actualité
est ce que toutes les françaises et les
français on a été très touchée en
bouleversé par le départ de johnny
hallyday il ya une chanson que j'adore
mais je vais vous faire sourire si je te
promets voilà c'est une chanson qui
appelle une bonne chose est une histoire
différente des autres trucs
merci beaucoup apprécié alors participer
au café un politique
[Musique]
et